o bonde conhecer pessoas é que um dia
elas podem representar a você mesmo o
bom conhecer pessoas é que um dia elas
podem apresentar a você mesmo
comece com isso porque foi o que
aconteceu comigo quando eu tinha 19 anos
e cursava jornalismo e eu vi na internet
sobre o massacre e pinheirinho uma saga
de pneu foi uma violenta e injusta de
ocupação o que aconteceu no interior de
são paulo foram mais de 8 mil pessoas
que tenham sido violentadas e na
televisão não aparecia nada
eu fiquei muito indignada mostrei o
vídeo pra minha amiga natália e juntas
decidimos fazer alguma coisa
dividimos a pagar a passagem de avião em
10 vezes já que morávamos em outro
estado
colocamos a câmera na bolsa e fome
a necessidade de fazer alguma coisa
porque encontrei lá foi isso
uma situação de calamidade pública
crianças dormiam no chão misturada com
lixo pessoas passavam fome
o local que elas estavam ficou conhecido
depois como campo de concentração
nosso objetivo era ouvir e registrar a
história dessas pessoas
o resultado foi o nosso documentário
chamado somos todos
o documentário rodou o brasil ela ganhou
vários prêmios
a gente recebeu mensagem e todo mundo
quer ajudar
eu pensava que a gente precisava
primeiro se importar para começa a ouvir
mas com esse projeto eu descobri que
quando você começa a ouvir você pode
começar a se importar
e quando você se importa você vai lá e
faz alguma coisa e se eu descobrir com o
filme que eu fiz chamado a praça é pra
quem nele eu amanda e juliana filmamos
uma uso de uma praça na zona norte do
recife
uma empresa que tenha adotado essa praça
no sentido de cuidar mas na verdade fez
um estágio
lamento neste vídeo a gente dizia se
você é contra e acha que isso é errado
manda uma mensagem para a prefeitura as
pessoas mandaram mensagem as pessoas
ligarão as pessoas fizeram um protesto
em um mês
essa praça foi reformada foi quando eu
percebi que o audiovisual pode
transformar o mundo
apesar de ouvir diversas pessoas
eu percebi que eu tenho um problema eu
não consegui ouvir bem as pessoas que
estavam do meu lado eu percebi isso
quando eu tinha 21 anos e um grande
amigo mel foi diagnosticado com câncer e
ligou pra mim e disse que tinha 80% de
chance de cura mas eu não ouvi
pra mim 80% e 0 1% na mesma coisa porque
eu já tinha na minha cabeça de câncer é
igual à morte e que por causa disso ele
iria morrer
o que aconteceu foi que eu comecei a
mandar várias mensagens para ele
eu fiquei desesperada mandava mensagens
para ele todo dia e daí ele me disse
bruhn eu estou me tratando não precisa
disso
tentando me adaptar eu acabei me
afastando dele só para depois eu ouvi
bruto também não precisa abandonar
eu não sabia como lidar com meu amigo
isso é muito difícil pra mim
outro momento muito forte foi que eu
percebi que eu também não estava ouvindo
ele eu participei do momento do corte do
cabelo
esse momento pra mim é muito forte nas
pessoas que têm câncer porque é como se
fosse a legitimação a partir daquele
momento não teria mais o que fazer
estaria no rosto na cara eu tinha muito
medo de como as pessoas a olhar pra ele
na rua
será que tratar bem pra minha surpresa
as pessoas darão parabéns
para quem não sabe a quem recife no
brasil é muito comum que o homem jovem
corta o cabelo quando entra na
universidade
então as pessoas acharam que ele por ser
jovem e careca que entraram na
universidade
a mulher ela acha que a sobrancelha foi
quando eu pensei se um homem jovem e
careca é porque entrou na universidade
os homens mais velhos são carlos mas se
fosse uma mulher uma mulher pessoas
iriam achar estranho que se fosse comigo
será que as pessoas vão me dar parabéns
pra casinha ter pena de não ter
curiosidade como eu me sentiria como eu
disse eu não sabia lidar direito com o
meu amigo quando uma mensagem quando
ficar quieta quando o sorriso quando
fica triste foi quando eu tinha vontade
de fazer um livro chamado o peso do
vento
nele eu entrevisto quatro mulheres que
estão passando pelo enfrentamento do
câncer e faz uma pergunta pra elas
como foi para você perder o seu cabelo
eu sei que falo de câncer
a estética talvez não seja a coisa mais
importante se pensar mais importante foi
que descobri que o levante é muito mais
relevante do que eu pensava eu descobri
isso conversando com laire ela tinha 60
anos e disse pra mim que era muito pior
perdeu cabelo do que retirar a mama
ela disse que a mão mas serve para fazer
sexo pra dar de mamar para os filhos mas
ela já era viúva e os filhos estavam
crescidos
então pra ela a mãe não tinha função
social mas o cabelo sim o cabelo era
visto por todo mundo do livro surgiu o
documentário meu novo sonho se chama
além da cura
um documentário sobre o empoderamento
feminino de mulheres
um câncer ao redor do mundo no qual a
gente investiga como a sociedade
influencia nesse enfrentamento mostrar
um vídeo pra vocês agora
hoje já me sinto muito feliz
nós somos um dos maiores que não tinham
coletivos de recife
em alguns momentos eu achei que a gente
não ia conseguir
era algo novo era algo difícil fazer as
pessoas doarem dinheiro para um projeto
que meu como e convence elas acreditarem
nisso
e foi quando eu e victor namorado e
companheiro do projeto
decidimos comprar passagem só de ida
para a europa
mesmo sem saber se vamos bater a meta
pra gente desiste não era uma opção
o projeto foi bem sucedido e ele foi o
ponto inicial para entrevistar mais de
20 mulheres no brasil e na europa
hoje a gente continua buscando recursos
para gravarmos na áfrica ásia e oceania
nessa jornada eu tive grandes presentes
um deles se chama catarina catarina
foram das mais jovens que eu entrevistei
batem tenha 28 anos era formado em
comunicação fame harry potter é e
maquiadora catarina dizia que a
maquiagem era um espaço de troca de
esperanças
enquanto ela ficava feliz e deixar as
pessoas mais felizes
ela também sentia assim então era
maquiar as pessoas para ficarem com mais
autoestima bem com elas mesmas e ela
sentia com mais autoestima e bem com ela
mesma também quatro meses após a
entrevista marina falecer
a gente evita foi muito importante
impacto da crise a gente foi no seu
enterro
e lá a mãe dela disse assim bruna não
deu pra catarina mas vai dar para muitas
outras sem retorno você não tem noção do
impacto além da cura na vida dela
depois podem entrevista pra você e fez o
vídeo e os amigos voltaram a se
aproximar as pessoas começaram a
entender o que ela sentia que ela estava
muito muito mais feliz
não para o seu projecto grana porque só
fazer ele já traz a mudança
outro grande presente que recebi se
chama desirrê ela foi uma das nossas
entrevistadas da alemanha mas o que eu
descobri não sou eu que vou contar vai
ser ela mesma através de um vídeo e
escuta muito calor e falta de estudo de
objetos explicam ó exatamente um dos
grandes problemas das mulheres com
câncer é que elas não são ouvidas e o
problema de não ouvir é que você cria
uma própria realidade na sua cabeça sem
nem ao menos saber que está acontecendo
de verdade como eu imaginei que o meu
amigo estava sem ó e perguntar pra ele
nesse projeto é aprender a ouvir ouvir
mulheres fortes era inesquecíveis
mulheres grandiosas que marcaram muito
uma coisa que me marcou muito também
disse rehn foi que a gente queria que
elas dessem entrevista enganar ativa
então eu perguntava pra ela inglês
ela responde alemão e depois ela falava
inglês de novo
o que ela falou enquanto ela falava eu
sorria quando ela sorrir e eu ficava
séria quando ela ficava séria
no fim da entrevista ela disse que
parecia que o real nem sabia que ela
estava falando só por eu estar na
posição mil e ela se sentiu acolhida e
entendida por uma pessoa que não sabe
uma palavra de alemão
desde que me falou também com as
dificuldades do projeto é que ela sentia
muito sozinha uma dificuldade no
enfrentamento dela porque ela tinha dois
filhos e um marido e não queria que ele
sem o peso da doença
então assim ele escondia isso todo mundo
bem e se sentia muito muito sozinha
desde g
eu não quero que você se sinta sozinho
eu quero te dar um espaço pra você ser
ouvida
você todas as mulheres do mundo que
alcançaram
se aquela bruna do começo vai ser ouvido
falar de rihanna
uma médica oncologista que cuidou de
vários pacientes e depois visões
paciente cuidarem dela se aquela bruna
tivesse ouvido falar vi ana lodi
portugal que após sofrer preconceito por
ter tido câncer de colo de útero começou
a dar palestras falando sobre sexo e
câncer e ajudou muitas mulheres se
aquela bruna que vai ser ouvido falar de
carla lado da frança que quando cheguei
lá para entrevistá me disse você veio de
outro país só para me ouvir
não tem noção do impacto disso a minha
vida aquela bruna que tivesse ouvido
falar de anne
mesmo doente que hoje cria sua filha eva
aquela linha tivesse ouvido falar de
theo
com a força de sua família unida feira
vencer essa doença
hoje eu quero falar pra vocês que estou
aqui em mais do que é isso meu amigo
caio estava doente e está cheio de vida
na platéia
dessa vez que meu mundo
e eu queria apresentar para vocês
todas essas mulheres maravilhosas que
mudaram tanto a minha vida
como eu disse odone conhecer pessoas é
que um dia elas podem apresentar você
mesma e hoje eu ouvi eu me conhece e
descobrir o que eu quero como propósito
da minha vida que é através do
audiovisual da oportunidade para todas
as mulheres cerca todas as mulheres
sejam realmente ouvidas